foundation and the board of directors of
the henry
salvatore center of claremont mckenna
college
the intercollegiate studies institute
and the clermont
institute in 2015
dr arn received the bradley prize from
the lynn and harry bradley foundation
recently he was appointed to former
president trump's
1776 commission which was
established to restore an american
education
an understanding of the history and the
principles of the founding of the united
states
published widely in national newspapers
magazines and periodicals on
issues of public policy history and
political theory
dr arn is the author of three books
liberty and learning the evolution of
american education
the founder's key the divine and natural
connection between the declaration
and the constitution and what we risk by
losing it
and churchill's trial winston churchill
and the salvation
of free government he travels tirelessly
to educate others and raise support for
the college
yet still finds time to frequent the
cafeteria
and have lunch with students as well as
teach classes
in politics and history he and his wife
penny have four children
henry katie alice and tony and recently
welcomed their first grandchild
charlotte
please join me in welcoming our
dedicated
and accomplished president dr larry arn
welcome back uh
i've enjoyed seeing your children these
last couple days
i'm sorry to say that none of them is as
attractive as our new grandchild
thank you carrie colleen mcginnis who's
setting the world on fire i thank her
very much we should all thank her
this summer homecoming is another crazy
thing she thought up
uh i'm confused by our awardees this
year three of them
one of them's not confusing
brent and kevin are very confusing
because
i can't think of them except as 19 years
old
they look a little older than that but
not much and
i saw their names on the list and i said
wait that guy
uh brent
football player ridiculous uh
dale allen is confusing because he looks
like he's 19 years old only marianne do
i understand
and that's because we've worked with her
a bunch and uh
she's always been the way she is right
now in my knowing
and i will tell you that it was a happy
day
when we offered her a job john cevini
did and she turned it down
and when john told me the news that she
turned it i said yeah it doesn't matter
she's working for free now
[Laughter]
i congratulate all of you that's a great
thing
uh i'll give a little report from the
college
we're having a schizophrenic here we
have just had a schizophrenic here
we never saw the like uh your uh
college staff i'm so grateful to them
we've been working together a long time
and we figured some things out
and this year we needed to know them
it's schizophrenic we
have had a spectacular year the best
ever financially
in admissions and recruiting new faculty
members and staff
the first 350 kids that did not get on
the wait list this year
are at the 92nd percentile in the
entrance exams
the freshman class this year is coming
in one point below harvard
we could have matched harvard if we
would just take all the ones who take a
put make a perfect score
but we don't like them showing up here
telling us how great they are
it's uh applications for faculty jobs
and all kinds of jobs they're just
awesome and they're people who could get
a job anywhere
we've hired a new choral director for
the sacred music program
and he built the sacred music program at
catholic university
he's 45 years old he's at the peak of
his career
and he's a big orthodox catholic and he
applied for our job
and i sat down in my office and i said
so why would you come here
and he said you know the answer to that
i'll tell you the answer to it
we are civil we have a common
mission we believe in it we
argue with each other freely but never
at the impairment of friendship or
collegiality
in other words it's a college
and there are very few left today
we've uh the lord has built all this
it's amazing you know the college is
prosperous we have uh
a net worth of over 1.1 billion dollars
up from 400 million 350 million
how'd that happen
so that's the happy part
this year has been 2020 has been a
disastrous year for the american nation
and placed it in my opinion in apparel
that's like the one
at the time that the college was founded
it's interesting thing about the college
that it's always been at its peak when
there's a crisis in the world
i think we're a college made to fight
ordinary times are not very good for us
it never happened before but this year
we got an order from the governor of
michigan to shut us down
and that was by the way an executive
branch
action alone and in 177 years we never
saw that
so we did decide to resist resist that
first i had to satisfy we had to satisfy
ourselves i had to satisfy
myself that this is not going to kill
college students
because the idea that a bunch of college
students
are going to be socially distanced it's
only possible to hold by somebody who
doesn't know anything about it you know
they uh the whole place turned into a
conspiracy
because like we have the protections in
place
and for commencement we observed them
because
the governor was watching and at that
time
last july the limit was 100 people
so we had 28 groups of 100
and you know we put all the protections
in place
and and the kids cooperated marvelously
and they knew they'd say to me we know
you don't believe in this
but we understand why we have to do it
well we told the governor six weeks out
and ask and two week four weeks out
two weeks out and we heard nothing
we can't tell and see what that means
that means
she wanted us to take the responsibility
for canceling this thing
but then on thursday as the people were
beginning to arrive
the deputy attorney general called our
local prosecutor
and said they're breaking the law let's
shut them down
and i can repeat the conversation neil
brady a very great man
i just gave him an honorary degree
having intended to do it for years
now we did it he said well they've got
all these protections
and they said yeah but they're over the
limit and he said yeah but
you've got that first amendment argument
which is why
the riots i mean the demonstrations have
been allowed to proceed
and the man said this is an attorney i
think
but this is a planned event
now parse that out for a minute you can
enjoy
your first amendment rights unless you
intend to do it at advance
right now the first amendment is the
first amendment because
it is amendment to protect the specific
operations of the human soul
right the second amendment is more about
the body
this is the highest thing right so then
neil brady gave him the clincher
argument he said you know
these are sophisticated people and
determined
and i have seen their legal papers and
you could be beaten here
and the deputy attorney general replied
i see you're right we shouldn't do
anything
do you know what that means he's just a
bully
why are we having commencement it's our
job
last year we got seven percent of our
revenues from the students here
we hope to make it zero because then by
what by by crack it will really own them
and they'll have to do everything
because you can you know you have to
turn it into a college into a
partnership
everybody has to know why they're here
everybody has to think the same thing
about that
and then the myriad inconveniences
and disadvantages don't seem somebody
else's fault
and we've done that here and
it's the proudest thing we've done by a
lot
there's no reason for any of us to argue
because we've agreed about the ends now
we just fight about the means all the
time
lord do we not do that but they're never
very serious
and
another college president because i was
trying to shame the athletic conference
into heaven sports
and see they get 85 or 90
of their money from the students
but 70 or 80 percent of that actually
comes from the government
and i said to him i said to the athletic
conference i said can you feel the life
seeping out of your college
i know they're not paying you any money
but the government does and they won't
pay if they don't come why would they
come
and the one of them said to me but you
don't get your money
that way i said no we don't
and they said then why do you care so
much
and i said there are just two reasons
one of them is
this turns out to be my line of work
we said we would we love it
but the second reason is like unto it
the activity here this is all just like
a nuclear reactor
and it burns very hot and it radiates
the entire country
everybody knows what it is everybody
knows it stands up a minority hated for
that and that means we have enemies
and they're laying for us but on the
other hand
millions of people think it constitutes
hope
we're very determined to keep that going
the race riots come and so now everybody
the only way to be safe is to confess
that you're a racist and call everybody
else one too
and that means by the way that the only
safe harbor is a lie
and that can't be a safe harbor
so we didn't do that you know
nobody else failed to do that
and now there's a new majority in
america by hook or by crook
mostly crook i think
and everything is threatening the tools
are in place
to destroy hillsdale college
some of them were put in place by
republicans by the way
but now there are people in charge who
would like to do that
i've said forever because i'm cursed by
a knowledge of politics
i always said you know you're the ones
people say to me that are independent of
the government
can't be harmed by it i always say you
should learn more about government
because if this country becomes a
despotism then hillsdale college and
everything else will be desperatized
and that means you could just easily
make the argument today
that this is a losing battle
i have said to the board three times
because i don't own the college they
don't own it either
it belongs to the beneficiaries that
means none of us knows
owns it right it belongs to the people
it is meant to serve
down through time and we
whom it has served oh a special amount
because we're supposed to preserve it
for the ones who come later
by the way you are the group who
understand that
which is why you sit in this room and i
can't tell you how grateful i
am to you
i said to the board i said you know we
have some money now
and we could afford to run the college
more quietly
and that might not be dangerous
and that's your decision i have to
present the option to you
well the first time i said it i couldn't
get him to talk about it
and the second time i said it a
different board meeting i said you you
have to talk about this
you have to figure it out because
things are going to happen probably
and so they did they talked about it for
about six minutes
and nobody nobody wanted to do that and
then chairman broadback said
so what would we do if you said yes we
said yes to that change
and i said well i do not come in here to
give the board an ultimatum they
represented the highest authority
the beneficiaries of the college i work
for you and you work for them
and so if you told me to do that i would
know how and i would set the college on
that
path and and then broadband said what
would you do after that and i said well
i'm in the world conquest business i
would go
look for a way to do that
because it cannot be permitted
that the freedom of the american people
is compromised because we are still
the last best hope of mankind on earth
and it's in peril now
i told the board last week i said
there are three things happening here
each one of which
in 10 years might be bigger than the
college is today the whole college
the governor of tennessee has just asked
me to open 50 charter schools
and promised me that they'll all be
approved and that they'll all be quickly
funded
and i said well governor that's hard and
he said
why is it hard and i said well how many
charter schools you got now
and he said 70. i said are they any good
he said no and i said well it's easy to
build that kind
you know the good kind takes talent
see there's hannah right if that girl
doesn't end up working for me i'm going
to shoot her
because she went to hillsdale college
and she's talented
and she'd better get her tail going to
save the world
our weapon is teaching
we've got a remote education center in
washington dc
four buildings now a graduate school
it's just
thriving and they all want to come here
and get a phd
and you know some of them are senior
people on congressional committees
and we've got one we just opened in
summers connecticut
that contains an exact replica of
monticello and we just had a conference
in there
for the first time and the guy who gave
it to us the founder of friendly ice
cream
gave us 25 million dollars to take care
of it
the commissioner of education in florida
was here the other day
and he brought a bunch of board members
from an unnamed college
i i won't it's a florida college and
i'm used to we're used to board members
and
presidents coming here to ask us how the
hell do we do this
they always say how do you raise all
that money and i always say i don't
and they say who does and i say the
people who give it
very important to remember that fact
makes every one of them a partner with
us
and a full partner with us anyway the
commissioner of education came to say
that he wants to take over
civic literacy training in inner cities
in florida
because in our 25 charter schools in our
academy we have never failed to graduate
a kindergartner who could read
and the reason they can read is because
they can already read
because they've already learned to talk
and nobody taught them that
little what's his name mariano rivera
the baby of reagan cool whatever her
last name is now
and she's sort of my girl right but that
boy he's
six months old five months old he's
going to be talking in a year and a bit
and nothing can stop it well reading is
the same principle you just have to
figure out that the sounds also apply to
marks on a page
he said i want you to do all of that i
said okay i'll talk to him
that's a lot he said you can do it
i don't know if we can do it i just know
that we will
then the guys from the college come and
they explain what's going wrong in their
college you know
it's woke and it's all this and we're
drifting
and i said you're not drifting you're
dying
liberal education is dying in america
there are 963 private colleges
mark caldhoff gave a really great talk
today and he pointed out
that's like a hundred thousand kids go
to all those colleges put together
against the millions who go to the third
and fourth
and eighth tier public universities
where the education is not what you'd
call elite
and i i don't mean elite to be elite
i mean suitable to make an excellent
human being
that's what they're for and they don't
do it
now and they said well
how can we stop dying
and i said well you're going to have to
understand it's a war
you're actually going to have to risk
everything every day
he said what would you do about the woke
faculty
and i said well if i committed the evil
of hiring them
then i would have to fire them
well the plot revealed at the end is
they want to give us that college
but that's one of about six right now
and we're not going to take them all but
we might take that one it's kind of
pretty
and it's a good spot and
and you see our online courses
almost three million people have taken
them we added uh
what did we add four hundred thousand
last year
and uh a really inspiring man named tony
batman really his name
a texan he's given us 20 million dollars
to endow them
but on condition that we spend an extra
seven million dollars
marketing them so they can get really
big
and that's you know not everybody could
make that deal but we can afford to do
it
and we're going to start these dual
enrollment courses which means we'll
give
academic credit and that means that if
if those go we're going to start them
pretty soon and if they go
then mitch klingenberg who's in this
room
and paul mueller who's in this room
they're going to go into a more honest
line of work than the one they're in
right now
we've always been good when we're
hurting
and i'm proud i came here because of
that i found that out
i never wanted to work a college day in
my life and never did work in a college
a day in my life until i came here
but i learned about those people who
went to gettysburg and that they were
students of friends of abraham lincoln
and i thought that's a calling
why don't we do that again
i think we have been appointed to do a
great act
in the cause of human freedom likely
at great cost to ourselves
and we're going to try to find the
courage to do that
thank you for being here
thank you dr arn the hillsdale college
alumni association was organized at the
close of the civil war
upon its founding the association
adopted its own mission statement
which called upon its members to keep
the alumni fully informed
help maintain the standards of the
college
aid in the enrollment of new students
and encourage
all alumni to tangibly support the
college by developing programs
to ensure its continued growth
today our thirty member alumni
association board works hard to lead
more than
fifteen thousand alumni association
members
to honor and uphold this 152-year
commitment for nearly 70 years it's been
a tradition
to hold a banquet to recognize the
achievements and service
of some of our most outstanding
graduates
this is what brings us here this evening
and tonight we will be recognizing
five outstanding alumni their
achievements
are detailed in your table programs and
i encourage you to read them
if you have not already done so i will
make an introduction of
each honoree and it will be followed by
a short video
after which dr aaron and i will present
their award
and each recipient may make a few more
remarks if they wish
so let's begin our first honoree this
evening
is kevin myers class of 2009.
kevin myers is the co-founder and ceo
of lucy darling a line of boutique
children's products sold now in
thousands of stores
across the globe since graduating from
hillsdale with majors in history
german and education kevin moved to
arizona to teach
a few years later he met his wife haley
who is the creative vision
behind lucy darling's brand shortly
after their first child lucy
was born the two decided to take haley's
etsy business to the next level
kevin eventually quit teaching and
worked alongside haley to start
and develop lucy darling full-time
since its incorporation in 2012 kevin
has grown the brand to sell
and ship globally three of the top 10
best-selling baby albums on amazon
are lucy darling products and you can
find them
in small and large retailers such as
anthropology
nordstrom land of nod kevin and haley
are active in their church and love to
travel globally together with their
family
kevin is also an active volunteer for
the college
serving admissions hosting alumni
receptions at his home
and flying back to campus to speak on
entrepreneurship
he's also a member of the president's
club he and hayley have three children
lucy june and bear please give your
attention to the screen to meet our 2020
young alumnus honoree kevin myers
for me the big picture is really
trying to you know understand the things
that are going to be meaningful to my
friends with my kids or
telling them a story i think it's just a
reminder that it matters because it's
really hard to do those little things
sometimes when you're not feeling it and
as a parent
you're usually not feeling it and so our
vision was to create a simple
beautiful baby brand to help moms
make their lives easier at first the
first several years we were just
hustling and we were just
working hard i was up late we were
receiving pallets to our house
it was just time after time after time
people would ask me questions i had no
idea
and it felt like it was a year before i
was asked a question that i knew the
answer to
so i was at basis scottsdale for a
couple years teaching
and then i moved to a christian school i
was running their admissions program
during that time is when we started our
business
lucid drama so in the winter of 2012
my wife had this idea
what she had when she was pregnant for
our daughter wanted to create a really
beautiful product that would be helpful
for us to remember how old she was as
she was growing
a little sticker to put on her onesie
as she was getting older month by month
she said actually
because i can't find anything maybe
there's a whole other market
something that we could do and she said
but we need to invest a little bit of
money
how much money we're talking about here
i mean this is really going to cut out
of that teacher salary
three-day conversation about this this
seed money investment of 100
us dollars i said all right i trust you
let's let's put all the money
you know a lot of students have this
grand vision of what they're going to
accomplish
once they graduate from college that was
not my story
my story was i didn't really know what i
wanted to do as i finished high school
my economics teacher from my high school
took us down i came
i think it was a lecture from dr wolfram
and while i was on campus i was walking
by
the library and out walked clarence
thomas
that was pretty cool and so seeing him i
was like
huh i think i should give a little bit
of thought to this place
uh and so at hillsdale immediately i
just
fell in love with the place it was
maybe my junior year but there was a
restaurant there called saucy dog i
don't know if it's still there
but we had i think on tuesdays
night and my roommate and i decided hey
you know what i bet we can afford to
take a professor out to dinner you know
what's he going to eat 12 wings
you know we had tons of guys out for
for
there's all kinds of challenges that we
face you know having kids is tough being
married is tough finding business is
tough
and so you need to be bold enough to do
difficult things i was able to see if
hillsdale these wise men and women
who cared about me and were able to give
good counsel
so as i've seen other challenges
challenges at work
jobs that i've had before challenges in
marriage challenges in raising
my children i've gone back to that
sort of habit that i've created which is
you know one of the things that has been
truly
helpful with our business because my
wife is very talented
she's very good at making beautiful
things and so
you know for me my goal and my job
basically from the beginning has been
how do we sell this
so first we started the business on etsy
that's where we were doing
all of our business for the first year
and then we expanded to amazon
but that i think that year was full of a
lot of challenges
because i had no idea what i was doing i
didn't know
lingo i didn't know process i didn't
know anything and so i had to figure it
all out
on the fly while we were selling when we
first
landed a deal with nordstrom we had a
100 page by eleven pdf
that i had to read in order to
understand how to ship boxes to
nordstrom
and so these things were so overwhelming
at first
and we just had to fly through we were
receiving pallets to our house
on mondays we would get a pallet or two
or three delivered to the garage
and we would on that evening we'd bring
everything inside and then we'd have to
label it and do all kinds of stuff with
it and then the next day would be the
pickup
and we would have to have everything
palletized and it would be pulled out of
the garage almost
three days a week was just that process
because we were getting bigger
and more orders i think when someone
asks your question you have no idea how
to answer
especially when you're trying to create
a brand and a business
it's it's really humbling uh because
you're trying to figure out
how do i answer this correct question
correctly but
also not foolishly
since then we've been able to bring a
team together we have a warehouse a
fulfillment center and so
one of the things that's been really
neat is one to be honest
is just that my wife's a very talented
designer
it's been awesome to see her strength
working together to
sort of give the world these beautiful
things that she has created has been
really satisfying
thank you kevin dr earn is joining us up
here
she's
that man married almost as much above
himself as i
on behalf of the alumni association of
hillsdale college it's my great honor to
present you with the young alumnus
award for outstanding professional
achievement
in entrepreneurship and i give you this
plaque
dr arne and i will give this to you it
is dated september 12
2020. we're just a little behind
we stepped inside
well originally this wasn't optional um
but here we go uh you know it's funny
that dr arm was also confused by me
receiving this award because i
i shared that uh initial surprise when
colleen called me
in fact i i sort of half joked with her
that the well must
be running dry for her to give me that
call finally but
i'll tell you you know being back here
on campus hearing uh
the professors again and just seeing
some other
alumni it's clear that the well is not
dry in fact i i'm just so inspired and
so
honored just to be with you guys to see
what you all are doing
i'm hearing from mitch hearing from paul
you know it's just awesome taylor what
you guys are doing in nebraska
it's just inspiring
yesterday morning dr connor delivered
his final lecture at hillsdale college
for the fourth time
he outlined the the dominoes that fell
into the onset of the great war
the fall of some of these dominoes
seemed inevitable
while others were clearly the result of
a choice
similarly in each of our lives things
happen to affect our lives that are
outside of our control
and others occur as a direct result of
our choices
we tend to prefer to assign the bad
outcomes to chance
and the good to our own efforts i
remember about five years ago having a
conversation with a friend
and she was familiar with what was going
on she knew that we were
you know getting into nordstrom and all
this kind of stuff and
and she said to me in the parking lot of
our church she said wow
god's favor has really been on your
business
and it shames me now to say this but i
bristled
inside she didn't know but inside i i
thought to myself
well you don't know all the hard work
you don't know the late nights the
sacrifices
financial and otherwise they went into
creating what we had achieved
but this as solomon would say is vanity
when moses was delivering his final
lecture to the israelites
before they enter the promised land he
recognized our human depravity
and how we are prone to accept false
credit for god's blessings
he said lest when you have eaten and are
full and have built good homes and live
in them
and when your herds and flocks multiply
and your silver and gold is multiplied
and all that you have is multiplied
then your heart is lifted up and you
forget the lord your god
beware lest you say in your heart my
power
and the might of my hand have gotten me
this wealth
you shall remember the lord your god for
it is he who gives you the power to be
successful
there's a lot that goes into success
here at hillsdale we say that virtue
rejoices in the challenge but how do we
gain virtue
solomon said to seek wisdom like silver
and search for it as hidden treasures
this habit of seeking wisdom
beauty good the habit of seeking wise
counsel
these are things that i learned here
they have shaped and molded me in such a
way
as to be able to experience in some
small way
god's inestimable blessings
i don't have time this evening to tell
you how the hand of god led me to
hillsdale college
nor the ways in which he is guided
directed and enabled our business to be
successful
but i'm deeply grateful for my time here
i'm deeply grateful for the virtue that
i gained
for the people that i love and the great
wisdom and modeling that i received
i would be remiss not to mention a few
people
of course my wife who's at home with our
three kids back in arizona
who's made my dreams come true
to doc for his friendship um
to my parents always for believing in me
to my aunt and uncle for hosting me and
to my
my roommate tim who put up with a lot
but also had some
good conversations along the way uh
hillsdale college is a special place and
i'm very honored to have been chosen for
this award thank you
thank you kevin our next honoree this
evening
is brent ogle class of 2002.
brent and his wife lindsey join us this
evening from columbus
nebraska area brent is the co-owner of
blazer manufacturing
a company that specializes in
manufacturing athletic equipment
for high schools and colleges as well as
fuel storage solutions
in a separate division brent has grown
the business by 50 percent
since acquiring it in 2015.
when he's not managing his company or
spending time with his family
brent is serving his local community he
dedicates his time weekly to youth for
christ
a christian youth organization in
columbus they recently named he and his
wife the honor of volunteers of the year
brent is active in his church and also
serves on the columbus planning
commission
if that wasn't enough brent coaches
two football teams two basketball teams
spring and fall soccer and a baseball
team
and oh he's also the president of the
city ymca board
brent has majored in marketing
management at the college and was a
member of sigma chi
serving as president his junior year
he's
also a proud charger football linebacker
but his crowning accomplishment was
meeting and marrying his fellow charger
lindsey berlin lindsay was a pie five
played soccer
and is a valparaiso law grad brett and
lindsay are active volunteers
with the college serving in a number of
capacities and are members of the
president's club
the ogles have four children alexander
emma
liam and max please give your attention
to the screen to meet our distinguished
alumnus honoree brent ogle
i grew up only 30 minutes from
[Music]
was a very good time hillsdale the
football team
i knew i wanted to play football but the
collegiate level
i was gracious enough to give me a
scholarship to play
and play all four years really football
for me allowed me to come out of my
shell i was
shy quiet not very confident
football gave me compliments and
it totally changed the game for me
i think it all kind of plays going to
give
together
so then fast forward to my time at welch
they made
packaging we're not talking at home
they're doing
millions a day an opportunity came up to
be a general manager which was the
ultimate goal run a
branch running facility 27 years old
come in to a operation of about 45
people
one guy literally his nickname
first thing i did is i worked alongside
everyone there i learned their jobs i
did the jobs
i remember moving out there and i was
working
endless hours a day chicago hasn't
stress
family and so i was missing out i was in
the car
or i was at work more than it was at
home that culminated in a lot of stress
one time in particular i
the stress that got to me and i almost
blacked out i started to go out
and i caught myself and i started
thinking
is it worth black
we're in walmart we come out we sit down
and i have an emotional breakdown to my
wife
we were in the car together by ourselves
without the kids and
i thought he was just going to say
something and we were going to get out
of the car
we were going to continue on our errand
and then i realized
very quickly that he was
struggling and i was just so emotional
and i said you know
i knew that work was stressful but i
didn't realize
where he was emotionally i just feel i
can't
i can't do this you know i was just
talking to her and
just had to unload that and she had no
idea held it all inside
i just thought oh my gosh how do we get
ourselves in this situation and none of
this is worth it
in my gut i had been stirring for about
a year
i wanted to have a business
something that i could call my own
something that i could build a legacy
but i left welsh packaging and our
high schools and colleges our primary
sport is track and field
my customers that i deal with are
dealing with high school
sports and high school athletes and
collegiate teams
we get to talk sports with them at
trade shows and meetings and couldn't
imagine anything better
i didn't realize when i was there how
and football gave me confidence in that
aggressive
arena you know hung up the cleats and
i can't play anymore even if i try to
destroy a couple weeks or maybe
hospitalized so switch from the football
field
to an office life is pulled apart things
there's always diversity there's always
problems
that drives me to
that competitive nature is what has
given me
the tools professionally
there's a set of rules but at the end of
the day we're still
trying to win and i love to wake up and
try to win
all
brent on behalf of the alumni
association of hillsdale college
it's my great honor to present you with
the distinguished alumnus award in
management
congratulations
thank you and uh that was a great
introduction carrie and speaking of
introductions i need to start with a
quick story about president arn
uh so i was a senior at hillsdale and we
were invited to a dinner
uh at president aaron's house and the
guest of honor was pat sajak so we are
all excited and uh
you know it's a fancy dinner and a
celebrity there
and about 10 minutes before the uh
the dinner is about to start
president aaron comes up to me and says
bren you're going to give the intro
and the toast to mr sajak
my eyes were about this big and
talk about unprepared uh so he put me on
the spot and
i managed to make my way through it but
um
but thank you so thank you
um i am humbled
and honored there are so many people
that are so much more deserving of this
award than me and
i just appreciate it i appreciate
the award i want to thank uh first and
foremost
my wife and former hillsdale
grad as you heard uh lindsay so
my professional journey starts and ends
with her without her
support her guidance her patience
i wouldn't be standing up here
my parents who are here dave and barb
my dad taught me how to
to strive to be the best how to
to drive for that and
the work ethic i was front i was front
row to
one of the hardest working men um you'd
ever know
and my mom her humility
uh i learned her humility and her sense
of humor
couldn't do it without her
my in-laws are here tonight randy and
harriet berlin
and they have these jokes about in-laws
not true here i totally i love them and
their support uh and their love
has just been great my brothers
luke and nick and my other family here
aunt bonnie and my grandma shirley
and then my great friends this was a
this was a journey as you
saw there and everybody has their
journeys and this was a journey and
you're all
such important part of this journey uh
finally like to thank hillsdale college
you're not a number at hillsdale college
you're an individual you have the chance
to lead
you have the chance to succeed you're
given that opportunity here
and the free market values
the entrepreneurial spirit that was
instilled in me
so when this opportunity came for us to
have this little chance at chasing our
own american dream in columbus nebraska
i know those seeds from hillsdale that
were planted 20 years ago
i know that they helped give me the
confidence to seize that opportunity
thank you
better take this
receiving our second distinguished
alumnus award this evening
is dale allen class of 1981.
dale resides in scottsdale arizona and
is the former global spark
sports marketing director for the jordan
brand at nike
a native of toledo ohio dale majored in
business administration
and accounting at hillsdale while
dominating the free throw record on the
charger basketball
team a record he still holds today
dale was a three-time naia
all-american and was part of the first
class inducted
into the hillsdale athletic hall of fame
in 1997.
i'm told he's probably the best
basketball player the college has ever
had grace's course still to this day
after hillsdale dale was a member of the
usa basketball team jones cup
international in serbia he played
semi-professionally in venezuela
after spending 15 years in sales at nike
dale eventually transitioned to brand
management
working alongside michael jordan as the
global director
of the jordan brand dale's experiences
with jordan
and nike took him across the globe
managing relationships with signature
athletes overall brands including chris
paul russell westbrook derek jeter
mia moore he also fostered joint
ventures for sports organizations such
as the nba
nfl mlb nascar and the like
dale and his wife yolanda who could not
be here with us tonight have four
boys nehemiah emanuel christian
and joshua will dale please come forward
dale
um
russell westbrook back-to-back mvp's
all-star game
there chris paul regularly here there
working for nike and working for jordan
that's the biggest highlight
but just a moment in time where you
realize that the odds of being in those
moments
i must
of me
and i was there
um being from toledo ohio i saw a lot of
athletes
that went off to school they came home
sometimes after the first semester
and i had aspirations to do something
different
77 when i came in 76 81
i think six games like six and 23
and i didn't know that before i signed
on scholarships
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
a squad
[Music]
it's a different dialogue when you stop
scoring baskets
and no one's changing anymore
but if you want to be successful
four boys
was huge because now
working with athletes at the highest
levels
[Music]
it's always challenging for
michael was
[Music]
i was
there was no day that was the same
because the responsibility of always
having to be on
one thing that i can say in my 13 years
[Music]
to be invested in everything that i do
and you didn't have to
what's next
knowing the ride that i've had through
hillsdale coming up identifying a job
is
basketball
that's the world
[Applause]
on behalf of the alumni association of
hillsdale college
it's my great honor to present you with
the distinguished alumnus award for
outstanding professional achievement
in marketing congratulations
[Applause]
wow
i give honor to the lord who's my
personal savior
i had some things that i wanted to say
but there's so many things to talk about
and i
jotted some things down in my room today
but i realized that
i graduated in 81. so 81 makes me old
because i did the calculation right
before i left my room in
81 means 40 years
and they gave me two minutes to talk
for 40 years i can't do that
so if i take two and a half minutes
please have me back
or don't judge me but what i would like
to say to everyone here
is what a phenomenal ride
in an individual
that it feels their college
would have not given me a chance
that video that you saw wouldn't be what
that video
is i can only think of four words
that would put all of the 40 years
in perspective for me as a young kid
coming from toledo ohio
i am so grateful the scripture that i
left ohio
was i can do all things philippians 4 13
i can do all things through christ
which strengthens me and i believe that
and i sung that and every challenge that
i face
that's what held me together then
and now no one can tell me no because
god has already promised it to me
because it's written
it's documented it is in his word so
because of that
i can't go back to being a doubter if he
can
i'm living proof when i stepped on
hillsdale college
i had other scholarship offers and i was
talking to
dr aaron this after iron this afternoon
and i told him that it was
and money may not be aware of it but
dean hindi
was the president of the school at the
time and i came up for my recruiting
trip
and of course i didn't know what
hillsdale was about and i asked him
if you can guarantee me that as a
student athlete
that i can get out with the class that i
came in with
i'm yours and he said and i said but
there's one asterisk behind that i want
to get out
with a meaningful degree that would
allow for me to be
stereotyped as just a an athlete
and he said what would you like to study
and i said business administration
he said you got it i can guarantee you
that
and by the time the college coach came
up
to take me back down to the field house
to show me
what the opportunity was for basketball
that wasn't important
because dean hindi at that time gave me
a commitment
out of his mouth and to my father and i
that he would guarantee if i did the
work in the classroom that i would get
out with a meaningful degree
and the rest is history because
everything that i relied on when i left
toledo was just that one scripture
was philippians 14 philippians 4 13
i can do all things through christ i
didn't really care less what happened on
the basketball court
but the game of life began there my
journey has been
phenomenal but i must pause because that
video
i didn't get here by myself so there's
four things that i
definitely want to make sure that i made
a point to talk to all of you that
don't know me in this room that you are
learning about me
but i appreciate there's there's things
the four things that i want to talk to
you about is
they end with f-u-l
i'm grateful i'm grateful for this day
and this opportunity and i'm grateful
for all you that have
an opportunity to witness this my
teammates
the brothership and the brotherhood that
we've had on our teams
we're in 2021 now there's a lot of
division
among us but what hillsdale college done
for me
was prepared me for that video
and what i mean by that is i'm grateful
for that experience
because when i arrived at hillsdale
college and i actually saw the student
body of hillsdale college
there was not a lot of people that
looked like me
and to this day is still not a lot of
people that look like me
but i'm grateful because what hillsdale
taught me
in my four years that they don't have to
look like you
if they have the same foundation that
you have
and the desire that you have to be they
are like you
if i cut you or i cut myself what do we
do we bleed red
is that correct so in bleeding red we
are all one
and so what i realized from hillsdale
college is that when i got to corporate
america
there's board rooms that i sat in
there's athletes that i talk to
there's entertainers that i talk to just
the form of life
they all may not look like me but that
is the one treasure that i take away
from hillsdale college because it made
me prepared
my teammates my roommate are here
tonight and there's many more
that wanted to be here but they send
their appreciation for
this moment and this acknowledgement but
i'm grateful
i am so so grateful for the school
believing in me to give me a chance
when i came out of high school i didn't
have the academics that i needed to be
qualified to be at hillsdale college but
they gave me a chance
and then hillsdale college gave me an
option in life
to have that video done because my
option was
i got a guarantee from the president of
school
that i would get out into four years in
the class that i graduated with
that's the chance that i got and i took
advantage of that option and i got my
degree
majorly important the other folk
is thankful so it's grateful that i had
the opportunity and i'm
so thankful and i wish that i could come
up and introduce myself
to each and every one of you
but i just saw two young men go before
me as recipients
and we all have a story it is that
amazing and they don't look like me
but our stories and our passion and our
drive
is where we are all as one we hurt
inside we have feelings we have desires
we have things
that we're all aligned with and we don't
even know
there's one thing in life has taught me
is
you really don't know who you know until
you know them when you go through
something
and that's what i learned from being an
athlete when you go through tough times
you know who the players are and who the
players aren't
you build them up to be a player and for
me
being thankful for everybody that's been
around me
my grandmother who gave me philippians 4
413 my mother and father my father's
deceased
who would leave his seven to three job
and drive from toledo ohio and make it
here every home game before
tip off and i was just talking to eddie
pieper
who was one of my teammates and i said
it's amazing now 40 years later
you and i are sitting next to each other
and our parents
bonded wasn't about color they bonded
through the vehicle of us playing an
orange object that was special because
now it's moments that we share with our
kids
that's what 40 years is all about our
teammates
our friends and family because my
extension to everyone in this room
is a big thing i'm from hillsdale
college
and i'm very very proud of that i'm
proud of the program
that is here right now i'm proud of the
athletics
that is here at hillsdale college i've
already
and i guess you can cut this off the
video
my 13 year old is committed to coming to
hillsdale college you don't know that
yet
but uh out of my four boys basketball
players
i had the three other ones play d1
basketball is very successful but
they're great in the classroom
and they're great individuals i'm a very
proud father
i've been married 30 plus years and i
got an awesome wife
to have done what i have done and her
for being supportive
and just the friends and family and the
prayers of everyone else i am so
grateful
the under is the other thing is
successful
there's a difference in learning about
being successful
my journey has been so amazing
so many stories to be told but through
the adversity
has made me who i am from the highlights
that you see of
working with special athletes and
engaged in their energy
that's all great because there's
historical moments but the lows of
having to deal with athlete to build
them back up to realize that
that's all fame and glory to give them
that foundation that i got from
hillsdale
because that's all i had a lot of it
that i'd never had
the pocketbook that pocketbook or the
wallet that they have
and i felt like i was out of place
because who am i
i'm just a little kid from toledo ohio
and i work for the jordan brand and
i don't have millions and millions of
dollars that i can throw away at
any given moment but it was a platform
that gave me the witness unto them
and in being able to witness to them who
my jesus christ saver is gave me a
platform to use that vehicle and use it
well
success is lonely and it's a long
journey
and it didn't and it's interesting
because the last time i was here
second to last time i was here i played
an alumni game
not good news not good news it is not
good news because
just the way that something happened
that changed my life
so there's a lot of things that's why
i'm connected to hillsdale i'd never
been taped before in the four years that
i played here
i never had never was injured i played
every game that i was here in the four
years that i was here now thank god for
that
but for me to come back an alumni game
and i got the new guys coming in it's
like oh your record's up there yada yada
and uh i understand you were good i said
i was okay
i come out on the floor and i'm going
through layup line and
i blow my knee out i hit the floor i had
no idea what happened
and so my wife and i at the time we had
to drive from hillsdale college back to
atlanta
to have my surgery and
that's the hurdle of coming back after
being hurt and never being hurt before
and this is after over playing ball
overseas and et cetera
i really understood now what it means to
be
a athlete because the challenge of
getting back up when you fall down
was something that now i had to deal
with
but through that transition because
again my scripture is i can do all
things through christ jesus which
strengthens me
i leaned on what's next for me and
what's next for me was to change lives
and individuals and as i sit across
in this room i see the lies that have
changed
at hillsdale college some of them are
here some of them are not
but i hope and i make a commitment to
hillsdale college
to help to change lives and to talk
about things that we can change and
learn from each other
because i'm passionate by that and if no
other day happens
i want you all to know that hillsdale
college
is a place for everyone for everyone not
just
people that don't look like me but
people that look like me
green brown and yellow whatever the
color you may be
because they are passionate they're
driven and they're committed
and as you look across our educational
platform right now we need commitment
and the education educators and et
cetera
we need to support you as much as
possible now because you're much needed
the responsibility and the burden has
got much heavier and we got to do the
lifting
the last one is respectful i am so
respectful and i can say this from the
bottom of my heart
i thank all of you for showing up for
this moment for me
it's priceless for the things that i've
accomplished
but those are just steps along my
journey
because before that journey occurred
those journeys occurred
i had my own stand-up playing basketball
where i was
held hostage before in havana cuba i've
held hostages in russia playing
basketball
those are the stories that made me and
build character of myself and
just who i am but but it was the road to
get me to what you just saw
in a snapshot but along the way i had a
lot of people that
i respected that gave me the advice and
to coach tarpon
the team here now they extended their
arms to me to come back and talk to the
kids about
the things and what i've done and the
alumni
the the committee that selected me to be
a part of this i'm grateful
and i'm very respectful anything that i
can do in my power to return
what you did for me today and did for my
family and this is
this recognition and award i deeply
appreciate this
it won't go unknown anything you want
from me anything i can do for this
school and this program
and these programs i'm here thank you so
much
thank you
our tower award is the alumni
association's top award for service to
hillsdale college
the tower is central hall the symbol of
the college's
courage resilience and steadfastness
this year's towers recipient exemplifies
all of these things and more as her
friend
and peer on the alumni association board
it is my honor to introduce marianne
rotoli class of 1995.
marianne joined the alumni association
board in 2012.
she has served faithfully for nearly ten
years
getting dedicating herself to the career
services committee
and eventually elected by her peers to
represent the board as secretary
vice president and then president each
of these terms
are two years and she's currently
wrapping up her service as
immediate past president marianne has
always said yes
when it comes to hillsdale whether it's
helping at regional events in chicago
speaking at career services and
admission events
hiring and mentoring students or
generously giving back
each year as a member of the president's
club marion's leadership on the alumni
association board
was particularly pivotal during a
transitional time
and her unifying and skillful approach
was a triumph
marianne's dedication to the college is
just one example of her commitment to
the things
that truly matter whether it's her
career
or her family and friends as a senior
vice president of octagon
marketing marianne has a demanding job
traveling the world
representing sponsors and brands in the
sports and entertainment industry
marianne was recently selected by her
peers and leaders to receive
octagon's 2018 mike burton award
recognizing fairness integrity
transparency and a commitment to doing
the right thing
personally and professionally at
hillsdale
marianne majored in english and was a
member officer of kappa kappa gamma
she is devoted to her faith and a
beloved aunt to 18
nieces and nephews marianne is
originally from
monroe michigan but currently resides
in chicago but she is moving back to
michigan school
now please give your attention to the
screen to meet marianne rotoli
i don't remember the year or the moment
exactly but i do remember thinking
what do i really believe in what
do i want the future to look like for
future generations
and it did not take me long to focus in
on
the things that i truly believe in are
my thing and the other
close second was hillsdale college
my route to hillsdale is a bit of an
interesting one because while i was
i would definitely say it was one of the
half the best decisions of my life
it was one of those that i made
unlike me without a lot of angst and
overthinking
i majored in english the greatest growth
i experienced while i was on campus was
definitely
in the area of confidence confidence is
something that
i think i struggled with as one of six
kids in a family you're always trying to
figure out who you are
where you fit in so this was the first
thing that i had chosen to do that was
different
than anyone else in my family had chosen
to do i was painting my own path
and at first i felt tentative about that
and by the time i got to
my senior year i felt confident about
who i was what my strengths were
quite frankly what my weaknesses were
but also i knew that i could forge my
own path
i felt confident i could go from there
to a new environment in my postgraduate
life
and be successful i started my career
with
the chicago bulls as an intern and
the rest is history
having grown up in newport michigan
which is a small town
my entry into chicago was a bit
overwhelming
the city felt massive to me i had to
figure things out by myself
or swim and i learned by trial and error
and i kept feeling that confidence that
i started to build a hillsdale grow
we knew at that time going into the
96-97 season we still had michael jordan
dennis
my first day with the chicago bulls
remember sitting down with the head of
the pr department
and he said there's a big party going on
here and you are part of it
and it's exciting but you'll be parking
the cars outside
and every day of my career i remember
that because
it reminds me every day to know your
role
and play that role as best as you
possibly can
so fast forward several years and i'm in
my fifth year with the chicago marathon
doing
pr and as luck or misfortune would have
it
the weather on the day of the marathon
was
oppressively hot and we knew it was
going to be a bad day
we cancelled the midstream due to mostly
the health of the back
of the pack the next year of my life as
a result of that was
personally and professionally very
painful because we were under a ton
of media criticism my phone rang
non-stop
every day all day four months and it
completely changed my perspective
quite frankly i became very burned out
from working with the media as a result
of that
and what i've realized is when you are
in moments of pain
you are growing that i was introduced to
working with an organization
called octagon sports marketing and knew
that if anyone was going to take a
chance
on converting a pr person to a marketing
person it would be the people that i met
and they did they offered me the
opportunity
what's really enticed me to maintain a
career in sports for as long as i have
is that team environment i realize i am
at my best
when i'm surrounded by other people who
are really intelligent
and very talented and very skilled and i
know i have a role to play at that table
so being part of that team that achieves
something remarkable
is the personal thrill i get from
working in this industry
one of the things i always wanted to be
part of was
giving back to my communities and
organizations that i care about
i have been volunteering with the
college
probably from near on the moment that i
graduated
i believe in its mission now more than i
did even when i was on campus
and i believed in that and at one point
i remember gregor haystead who was the
head of alumni relations at the time
said would you ever
consider joining the alumni board and my
response was
would the alumni board ever consider
allowing me
membership of course and i'm finishing
up my eighth year
of service on board and i've enjoyed it
immensely
you know once i got onto the board we
looked at new ways to get
alumni involved on campus for the two
years that i was president
it felt very much like any other
consulting meeting i could go into with
a client
and i'm a problem solver so i'm looking
at college objectives and saying here
are the 10 things i think we can achieve
and help you with over the next 10 years
it furthers my belief that things all
come together at the right time i think
i was the
right person at that time to be sitting
at the table
and talking about how we could shift and
change and move the board's
role probably the most beautiful part of
the board
is a very familiar
feel of family similar to debates that
you might have on campus we have those
debates in the boardroom
at the end of the day we also have such
an amazing time together
it reinvigorated my relationships
through the college you would think that
we've been
friends for decades it's it's one of
my favorite ways to spend my free time
i'll have you stand over here
marianne on behalf of the alumni
association it is my great honor
to present you with the tower award for
service to hillsdale college
thank you and congratulations
thank you dr arn a man i am very proud
to call my friend
after many years of of speaking together
thank you also carrie
i frequently reference carrie as my best
friend from college
and we graduated 20 years apart and i
mean that sincerely she's
she's a mentor and a friend she also
talks me up really well which is super
sweet
i also want to thank john cervini gregor
haystead
colleen mcinnis ken koopmans
joanna wisely jeff lantis it's his fault
i'm here
you guys and all the faculty and staff
at hillsdale college you not only
admitted me um and have invited me and
given me opportunities to stay involved
with the college that i love
but you maintain its virtue and you
complete its mission daily
so that we all have a meaningful cause
to which we can contribute
it's an honor to be affiliated with this
institution
and it's an honor and a privilege to be
affiliated with the other three
gentlemen that have been recognized
tonight
i'm pretty confident if the four of us
get together we can do something pretty
remarkable
i wrote down my words of acceptance last
august
but much has changed since then i lost
my dad dekoved in january
he was my hero and a warrior for this
college
a true warrior for this college it is
because of him that i'm here
while dad was in his final days he asked
us to read things to him
it was tough for him to talk he talked
but it was tough for him to talk
since we didn't know if this evening
would ever happen i read him my speech
he told me it was perfect something he
did not say often
am i right yeah he did not say often so
if you'll allow me
i would like to read it as i read to my
dad who i know is here tonight
my niece maria tyson who is a proud 2018
alumna of hillsdale college and
kappa is quasi-obsessed with enneagram
tests
and she's pretty darn good at predicting
what number will be assigned to each of
her family
members and friends she called me out
immediately as a two
which if you boil it down to a one word
description is a helper
or a giver it irritated me that she was
right
not only because i despise being
predictable but because i thought
immediately
so i help others and that's it am i
incapable of achieving myself
have i no talent at all or am i simply
afraid of using them
i was humbly reminded shortly after that
of the importance of such a role
i was attending mass at my home parish
of old saint pat's in downtown chicago
which by the way has the most beautiful
and inspiring musical liturgy
i have ever experienced i invite you all
to come sometime when when you're in the
windy city
as i was sitting in my standard balcony
seat that sunday
the choir tuned up one of my favorite
songs a divine intervention
to remind me of the great words of
mother teresa and the importance of
service
we can do no great things only small
things
with great love if i have offered
any service to the world to this college
or otherwise
is because of the role models of my
parents
they introduced me to my faith and my
god
they instilled in me a pride for my
country and the freedoms it provides
the appreciation for the blessing of
family
two of my beautiful talented and
siblings are with me here tonight
and they introduced me to hillsdale
college
i am blessed to have learned love
compassion
and the importance of giving to others
from my parents joseph and cheryl rotoli
if i have contributed good to this world
it is because of you mom and dad
this award is an extension of you
i leave you with this thought on the day
the team visited me in chicago for the
filming of by the way these remarkable
videos
i read the daily gospel which
appropriately came from matthew 10
and perfectly epitomizes the way i view
my role
as an alum of this college without cost
you have received without cost you are
to give
thank you
this concludes the presentation of
awards congratulations again to all can
we give a round of applause one more
time for our wonderful recipients
i'd now like to ask colleen back to the
podium for a few closing comments
that was very inspiring
and touching thank you carrie and dr
arnan congratulations again to all of
our very deserving
honorees i'm sorry
i have a few short marianne man
i have a few short housekeeping
announcements before we adjourn
this has been a very fun weekend thank
you all for coming for those of you who
are here
this whole weekend there's a lot of work
that went in from
many people from the marketing
department putting together
all of the branding and the pieces brian
springer who designed everything is over
there
to bone appetite to maintenance to
obviously my team which i'm going to
mention in a minute
but is a lot of moving parts we had a
lot of fun
it was fun seeing all of your kids i
hope they loved it here
as much as we all do and hopefully that
will put a spark in their hearts
for later on but i have a few things
that
some little business details to get get
out of the way
before we end the formal our formal
program and
party more in the back um but i invite
you to stay for that after glow in the
reception area
immediately following this program we
are very happy that our faculty jazz
band the hillcats led by our director of
jazz ensembles and trumpet teacher
chris mccoury was available to be part
of the program tonight
they'll be here throughout the afterglow
and i'd like to see you all let loose a
little
out there on the dance floor before the
end of the night i will be serving
brunch
tomorrow in the gru cox student union
which is
the dining hall as a sunday brunch
option
it'll be a little more upscale than the
last two mornings as our sunday brunch
the brunch will run from 9 to 12. i
highly encourage you all to join us for
the worship service in christ
chapel at 10 a.m dr ken calvert will be
giving the message
and we'll have special performances of
sacred music by several students
and our organist it will be lovely and
the chapel is an
experience in and of itself in case
you were tempted don't forget to pick
your kids up at camp in the morning
between eight to nine for those of those
kids that are at camp meshendo
we scheduled the morning the way we did
so they could join us for lunch or
for brunch and worship in the chapel
we'd love to see you
and them there i want to acknowledge
the alumni office staff and our student
team for coordinating and executing a
wonderful weekend
it has been a fun pilot project we'll
see what the series holds
i want to particularly thank ashley
salos who joined the alumni team
late late last summer and hit the ground
running with this major event
she hit the ball out of the park
she's worked tirelessly and without any
stress which would not be my story if i
was in her shoes
thank you ashley at least you didn't
show your stress um
lastly i'd like to thank dr aaron and
john cervini for supporting this idea
this white and blue weekend and
participating in it amidst a very busy
time for the college
our alumni are a very important part of
the hillsdale family
and spending time together will continue
to build that relationship
for a lifetime so mark your calendars
homecoming and our 2021 alumni awards
banquet
will be on september 24th and 25th
because remember
this is the 2020 awards banquet which is
why your awards are all dated in
september
it's been such a joy to welcome you all
back to campus for this special weekend
i've enjoyed getting to know many of you
and we hope that through programs like
this our national alumni receptions and
homecoming
you'll continue to stay connected to the
college for the rest of your life
as you know there's no place like it we
need hillsdale college now more than
ever
thank you and enjoy the rest of your
evening
you